hello and welcome to this video playing
em western that's a frequent opponent I
think I always look about and there's no
name and hey oh it's curious ok anyway
we have a an English opening here with
Quincy too and it's a little bit like an
imbecile but white hasn't played you for
that can have its pluses and minuses and
1 plus definitely is that my center is
pretty flexible and sometimes you can
play it without without the d point ever
moving ok me melt I'll just develop him
haven't castle yet that could be
interesting uh-huh ok I think he wants
to go E 4 ok let's have a look at this
and then play before next hmm it's
interesting in this position to play the
movie form simply block the whole thing
but hmm i wonder algo que if I it's not
really a threat from now it's not a
threat d5 sometimes can be an idea
you
b5 those d5 yeah okay I don't want to
play three for that it's very young and
very stodgy looking what a bit of a bit
of dying dynamism at least plenty form
with white can be an idea if I have even
more space whoa
okay hi that looks nice right it's that
a nice position look to you one let's
see well looks like you have very
nice-looking diagonal them 95 and Bishop
f3 looks good or am i rushing things and
it's difficult I mean the night on g5 is
kind of is unprotected but he can hardly
move this night with this pressure oh
wow asics ok Bishop f3 and then wow the
move Knight e5 is funny Knight takes
that's made on g7 and Queen takes as
Bishop f3 that's a funny move ship
everything edge that now that works
right Valley move the big thing is that
d6 is hanging maybe you can go d 5 by
the way maybe you can go 25 just losing
a pawn I hope I'm not miscalculating
such a flashy move and that it isn't
working for some reason but it doesn't
seem to at least fail to something
simple ok um where'd you go well yeah
it's not so easy Bishop is 6
will actually attack my take my seafoam
pond maybe I have to have to play this
in an aggressive fashion if you take syd
that that's a pin that you probably
cannot stand Bishop see one should win
stuff I think I'm probably threatening
age 39 age 6 g form something like that
yeah age 3 is a throat I guess can never
move this night on it from a six this is
really important always made on g7 yeah
I can go if or hear you
all based on the diagonal I saw this
idea even without bishop at 50 just I
just saw the idea now it looks even more
powerful okay Bishop t5 you cannot take
it now age three and push everything
back now Wow but you have a nice
position also with the porn CA 6b five
and so on black can hardly move any
peace very nice yeah okay and
fortunately I cannot decide it directly
but like Ruby idea that it's not
possible but he has a hard time you to
move anything mmm rupee seven hours is
fleshy but also strong I think
yeah I really hope the end Black reason
I hope the engine doesn't find any
representation of this because looked
like really nice look like a really nice
game yeah here I like my position looks
like good space advantage I was
surprised that he just went back but um
yeah it looks fairly fairly solid I was
just thinking he would go a five-year to
be honest just to block the whole thing
here I was thinking that white maybe has
a slight edge with the bishop palette
nothing nothing great I was surprised
that he allowed that I it's still okay
actually the engine gives this now
stockfish okay that makes an awful lot
of sense yeah just to try to trade this
this pawns yeah it looks good and I went
here and this is this is getting I'm
getting tricky 95 yeah and now this was
very surprising that he went back is
this and the engine wants to go bishop
f3 and not 994 okay the computer okay i
see the computer gives this law antiques
and he xq in here antiques and now 95
with this idea c4 hangs and there is
this is potential okay this is not easy
if i go here for example there is this
and cannot protect it
this is the best move i am not sure that
it would have been so difficult yeah why
should we invite it still this is still
work you know I'm taking this FYI said
kim Ok Computer wants to do this check
cause I didn't see that how carry that
also seems to be pretty good for why do
here yeah but am i winning this is
another thing hmm not sure stockfish
laughs my position 1.2 of it we're
probably invading some of it those skin
I'm sorry be five and a six can easily
drop not sure okay this and now I should
be in very good shape rupee one before
as powerful and going back yeah just a
check pushing pushing forward no sister
make it could barely move okay that was
a nice game I think he should have tried
to I think avoid this this clamp on the
on the queenside got got very tricky to
play after that was established and then
there was some some technical issues
okay well thanks for watching